this was one of the questions regarding
only fans and these are these men uh
these males responses go ahead
are only fans girls wifey material
absolutely not absolutely not hell not
absolutely not i would never wipe them
up rock around with them for a little
while wifi nope she's getting naked for
a camera she belonged to the streets
i cannot wife these girls man whoever's
watching this you just gotta stay away
from them if she's giving me some money
man you can show your titties you can
show your boo
i'm down with it just give me some of
the money what is wifey material and
what's the reason they're not because
when you think of a wife you think of
somebody that's somewhat conservative
someone that is exclusive for you but
the minute she starts talking anything
about marriage or whatever it's like of
course not honey she's going she's gonna
be a reflection of you
and and if she's posting yourself nude
online that's a reflection of you that's
a reflection of your leadership she's
exposing her body to multiple men or
she's sleeping around with multiple men
and i'm wiping that
so no
okay anyway subscribe to valuetainment
right there so what if we're together
then that's okay yeah i'm just going to
say this
that makes it slightly different yeah
100
you're you're doing it with your husband
they're talking about meeting a new girl
and wiping that yeah but what would your
response be to these men just so they
understand your position or even
only fans girls position
yeah i actually might be a little more
aligned with them than you think i think
uh from the outside if you are someone
who's already doing this and you're
going to look to marry them it could be
an issue because if that especially if
they're
wanting to continue to do that i don't
know that that is ready for wifey
material yeah tell us why though but you
are do you do only friends so are you
contradicting yourself well i do only
fans with my husband and we've been
married you know
19 years prior to us even
contemplating doing something and i
would have never done this um without
even his blessing like if he was like
are you out of your mind i would have
been like yeah i am i'm sorry you know
i'm crazy so i totally get that you have
a husband so talk you have the camera
yeah talk to guys out there
about why they should or shouldn't
wife up and only fans model
okay well my first concern would be that
if they're doing financially well on
there uh it's quite
difficult to turn that funnel of money
off and it
if they weren't willing to do that to
turn that off in order to for marriage
then i would call that a major red flag
um that would be one concern i also feel
like it's an area that maybe they may
venture back to or if you have a problem
with that going into a marriage or even
in anything if you already have a
disagreement about something that
serious like i don't want children
versus i want children like if something
like that kind of debate i just don't
think it's a good idea going into
anything like that but
i'm not saying it's anything to do with
like oh you shouldn't wipe them because
it's trashy or it's wrong by no means
but i just think people that are in this
industry that are doing and working it
as a business will probably want to
continue that i would imagine it's not
something that i mean i guess you could
just turn it off if if they wanted to
get married but yeah it'd be weird so if
you like that clip click right here to
watch another or if you want to watch
the entire sauce cast click right here
[Music]